hey everyone
welcome to another video by simply learn
in this video
probability density function we will
tell you everything that you need to
know about the probability density
function
and how to implement it both in python
and in real life so let's get started
so what can you expect from this video
what's in it
for you first we will go over the basic
definition of the probability density
function
followed by the steps to find the
probability density function
there are three main steps which is
summarizing the density using histograms
parametric density estimation and
non-parametric density estimation
and finally we will see how to implement
all three of these steps in python
so now let's dive into the definition of
the probability distribution function
what is probability distribution
function a function
which defines the relationship between a
random variable
and its probability such that you can
find the probability of the variable
using the function
is called a probability density function
in simple words probability density is
the relationship
between an observation and the
probability
some outcomes of a random variable will
have low probability density
and other outcomes will have a very high
probability density
basically the probability of a variable
x happening or occurring
will vary and it can sometimes take on a
lower value or it can take on a way
higher value
the overall shape of the probability
density is referred to as probability
distribution
and the calculation of probabilities for
specific outcomes of a random variable
is performed by a probability density
function or pdf for short
now consider a variable x with a pdf of
f x this is what your probability
density function will look like
there might be a point where the
probability of x
occurring is very high hence
your probability distribution function
or f of x will also be very high
at other points the distribution or the
probability of
x happening or occurring is going to be
very low
hence your f x is also going to have a
very small value
basically given the random sample of a
variable
we might want to know things like the
shape of the probability distribution
this here is something called a normal
distribution where a probability
distribution function
takes on a bell shape however this is
not
the probability density function that
might always occur
there are different probability
distribution functions and all of their
graphs look
very different from each other knowing
the probability
distribution for a random variable can
help you calculate
movements of the distribution like the
mean and variance but it can also be
useful for other more general
considerations
like determining whether an observation
is unlikely or very unlikely
and might be an outlier or an anomaly
like consider this graph itself in this
graph
these points over here which have very
less probability distribution
are outliers which means that the chance
of them occurring is very low and
basically
this is not something that you're going
to see in your regular
scenario for your variable x now let's
consider two points a and b
which are values that our variable x can
take
p of a and p of p just represent the
probability
of a and the probability of b which can
be found
out by drawing a straight line and
coinciding it with our graphs
the area under the graph over here
which is going to give you your
probability of this
region occurring can be written as
probability of
a less than equal to x which is a
probability that we're searching for
here
less than equal to probability of b what
does this
mean exactly this means that this area
is always going to be greater than or
equal to the probability of
a but less than or equal to the
probability of b
this gives us the narrow region
of the probability which is present over
here and doing this
we can find the probability of
occurrence for any value of x
suppose you want to find the probability
of b happening
for a probability distribution function
the probability of b
happening is not simply this point here
but the entire area of the graph which
is taking place
before this point itself so if you want
to find the probability
between these regions you're gonna have
to find the entire area
and not simply the probability at one
point
now so far we've been talking about
different types of variables which is
discrete random variables and continuous
variables
what exactly do these mean a variable
which can only take a value
within a certain range is called a
discrete random variable
the value is usually within a certain
distance of another finite value
an example of this would be the sum of
two dices
basically values which are well defined
are called discrete values or
and a variable which has well defined
values will be called a discrete random
variable
this variable can only take values which
fall within a certain set
of values let's say you roll a dice the
dice can only give you specific
outcomes which range from 1 to 6 this is
what you would call a discrete output
on the other hand a continuous random
variable can take on infinite different
values within a range of values
for example the height of a student the
height of a student
is not fixed even if the height is 1.7
meters in reality the height can be 1.77
or 1.765
or 1.78 the exact height is very
hard to determine because it's not easy
for us to find the precise
value of the height of a student so
basically the height can take on
an infinite different range of values
when we're trying to define the values
that a continuous random variable can
take
we usually say it in the form of a range
of values which means that the
value can fall in that range and can
take on any value in that range
it's not like a discrete random variable
where you can define
definitive values
now let's understand a probability
density function with the help of a
graph
consider the graph below which shows the
rainfall distribution in
and your inner city the x axis has the
rainfall in
inches or the amount of rain that we are
getting and the y-axis has the
probability density function of getting
that amount of rain
the probability of some amount of
rainfall is obtained by finding the area
of the curve to the left of it
so let's say we have a 0.3
if we want to find the probability of 3
inches of rainfall occurring
we would have to find the area of the
curve
which falls to the left of three when we
draw a line from three which intercepts
the graph
and further extend it onto the y-axis
we get a value of 0.5
simply put this means that the
probability of 3 inches of rainfall
occurring
is going to be lesser than or equal to
0.5
the exact probability can be found out
by finding the area of the curve
which falls to the left of three
how do we find the probability
distribution function
the first step is to summarize your
density with the help of a histogram
the first step in a density estimation
is to create a histogram of the
observations
in the random sample now what is a
histogram
a histogram is a plot which involves
first grouping the observation into bins
and counting the number of events that
fall in each bin
the counts of frequency of observation
in each bins are then plotted as a bar
graph
with the bins on the x-axis and the
frequency on the y-axis
the choice of the number of bins is
important as it controls the coarseness
of the distribution
and in turn how well the density of the
observation is plotted
it is a good idea to experiment with
different bin sizes
for a given data sample to get multiple
perspectives or views on the same data
at the same time the number of bins is
important as it determines how many
bars the histogram will have and their
widths this will change
not only the shape of the graph but also
how the graph is read
this will also determine how a density
is plotted
now let's see how we can summarize our
density with histograms
using python first let's import all of
our necessary modules
which we're gonna require we're gonna
require matplotlib to plot graphs
we're gonna need the normal random
function
so that we can get a normal distribution
we're going to import
mean and standard deviation from numpy
to use on our graphs
and also going to normalize our data so
we're going to
import the norm function from scipy
we finished importing all of our
necessary modules
now let's generate a sample
which has a size of thousand and it's
going to be a normal distribution
and we're going to also plot this with
the help of a histogram
in bins of 10.
so as you can see here you get a normal
distribution which is nothing but a
almost bell shaped curve and we have 10
bins here
which are centered at 0 and which extend
from minus 3
to 3. how will our
graph look if we change the number of
bins though
let's run it and see so you still have a
normal distribution but it's not as well
defined
because of how less the number of bins
are you lose a majority of the data
which will contribute to your normal
distribution it doesn't look like a
proper normal distribution but looks
more like
discrete data at this point now let's
take a look at the next step of finding
a probability distribution function the
next step is called parametric density
estimation
what exactly is parametric density
estimation
the probability density function is of
many types
the shape of your histogram will help
you determine what type of a function it
is
we can also calculate the parameters
associated
with the function to get our density now
different
probability distribution functions will
have
different graphs which will have
different shapes and which will also
have
different parameters like mean standard
deviation etc associated with them
using these parameters we can find
important
points of our data hence it's very
important for us to
recognize what type of a distribution it
is common distributions
will occur again and again in different
and sometimes unexpected domains
getting familiar with common probability
distributions will help you
identify a distribution from a histogram
and once identified you can attempt to
estimate the density of the random
variable
with the chosen probability distribution
this can be achieved by estimating the
parameters of the distribution
from a random sample of data now an
example of this would be a normal
distribution which has two main
parameters
the mean and standard deviation given
these two parameters
we will now know the probability
distribution function
these parameters can be estimated from
data by calculating the sample mean
and sample standard deviation this
entire process
is known as parametric density
estimation and it
includes identifying your probability
distribution function
and getting the parameters which are
associated with it
now once we have estimated the density
we can check if it's a good fit
this can be done in three different ways
one is plotting the density of the
function
and comparing the shape to the histogram
the next is sampling the density
function
and comparing the generated sample to
the real sample
and the last one is using a statistical
test to confirm
if the data fits the distribution now
over here as you can see all we've done
is
taken our data and plotted the density
function
on top of a histogram and we've compared
this shape
so the distribution so the density
function that we're actually considering
here
is a normal distribution and from this
graph we can see that it's almost an
exact fit to our histogram
now let's see how we can perform
parametric density estimation
using python to begin with
let's generate a random sample of 1000
observations
from a normal distribution with a mean
of 50 which is determined by the loc
parameter
and a standard deviation of 5 which is
determined by the scale parameter
now just to show you what the
distribution looks like we're gonna plot
it in the form of a histogram
so this is what the histogram looks like
but this is just to give you a basic
idea of our data
and what it looks like once plotted but
let's assume that we don't know
the probability distribution and and we
don't know what it looks like
as a histogram and we don't know that
that it's normal
so now if we just assume that it's
normal we can calculate the parameters
of the distribution
specifically the mean and the standard
deviation
we would not expect the mean and
standard deviation to be 50 and 5
exactly given the small sample size and
the noise in the sampling data
so because of this noise and the small
sample size we have
a mean of almost 50 and a standard
deviation of a little more than
five now let's define the distribution
as normal so now using this we've
defined a normal distribution
we've used the norm method of the scifi
library
and we're doing this with the mean
and the standard deviation that we've
obtained from our samples
so up until now we're just assuming that
it's a normal distribution
and because of that the parameters that
we've calculated
is the mean and standard deviation and
using the calculated mean and standard
deviation
we've gotten a normal distribution and
up until now again keep in mind we do
not know
for certain that it is a normal
distribution so far all we have is this
data
so the next thing that we're going to do
is fit the distribution
with these parameters and then sample
the probabilities for a distribution
for a range of values in our domain
which in this case
is 30 and 70. so all we're doing is
we're calculating probabilities for a
range of outcomes
and in this case we've taken 30 and 70
as our domain
so these are the probability
distribution values
for the normal distribution that we've
defined over here and this is gonna
uh this is basically gonna give you the
outline of your normal distribution
these are the points at which your
normal distribution will be plotted
uh now what we're basically gonna do is
we're gonna plot our histograms
using the samples that we've already
generated
along with the values and probabilities
of the normal function
that we defined over here
so as you can see it's an all it's
almost a complete
fit the normal distribution that we have
here
is made using the mean and the standard
deviation
of our actual samples
the reason we took mean and standard
deviation was because we assumed
it was a normal distribution and the
parameters associated with the normal
distribution
our mean and standard deviation using
the
mean and standard deviation we got the
normal distribution we calculated
probabilities for this normal
distribution using a random domain
of 30 and 70 and we plotted the
probabilities and the values
on top of our histogram to see if the
normal distribution was a fit to a
histogram
if it was not a fit you would have to go
and do the same procedure
with other common probability density
functions
until you found a function which was a
proper fit to your histogram
now let's move on to the final step
which is used in the calculation of a
pdf
this final step is called non-parametric
density estimation
and it's only used when the shape of a
histogram
doesn't match a common probability
density function
or it cannot be made to fit one in this
case we will calculate the density using
all samples in our data
using certain algorithms this is only
done when a data sample does not
resemble a common probability
distribution or it cannot be easily made
to fit the distribution
and this is often the case when the data
has two peaks
this is also called a bimodal
distribution or it has
many peaks which is also called a
multi-modal distribution
in this case the parametric density
estimation will not be feasible
and alternative methods can be used that
do not use a common distribution
instead you will use an algorithm which
is used to approximate the probability
distribution of the data
without a predefined distribution which
is also referred to
as a non-parametric method because we're
not using any predefined parameters
the distribution will still have
parameters but these are not
controllable in the same way as a simple
probability distribution
for example a non-parametric method
might estimate the density using
all observations in a random sample in
effect
making all observations in the sample
parameters
now consider this graph which has two
peaks
you this is not a normal distribution or
any other sort of distribution that we
are familiar with
so for this we are not going to use a
parametric
estimation method but we're just gonna
calculate
the parameters for every single sample
point in this
perhaps the most common non-parametric
approach for estimating the probability
density function
of a continuous random variable is
called kernel smoothing
or kernel density estimation or kde for
short
kernel density estimation is a
non-parametric method for using a data
set to estimate
probabilities for new points it uses a
mathematical function
and smoothing probabilities so this so
the sum of the resultant probabilities
is
always one now in this case a kernel is
a mathematical function
that returns a probability for a given
value of a random variable
the kernel effectively smooths or
interpolates the probabilities
across the range of outcomes for a
random variable
such that the sum of probabilities
always equals one
a requirement of well-behaved
probabilities
you also have a parameter called the
smoothing parameter
which controls the scope or the window
of observations
from the data samples that contributes
to estimating the probability for a
given sample
as such the kernel density estimation is
sometimes referred to as your paris in
rosenbolt window now at the end you also
have a basis function
which is a function which is chosen to
control the contribution of samples in
the data set
towards estimating the probability of a
new point this is only done
to make sure that you're not learning
from a lot of noise
and that you're not using a lot of the
outliers again
let's see how we can perform
non-parametric density estimation
with the help of python
so first we'll start by importing all
the necessary modules
along with the kernel density estimation
which can be imported from sklon now
let's
create a bimodule distribution by
combining two different samples sample
one
and sample two sample one has
300 examples with a mean of 20 and a
standard deviation of 5
while sample 2 has 700 examples
with the mean of 40 and a standard
deviation of 5.
we're then going to use edge stack to
comb to merge both of them together
to get a final sample
the means that we've chosen which is 20
and 40 are chosen close together to
ensure that the distributions overlap in
the combined sample
so this is what our distribution is
let's just plot it so you get a basic
idea of what our graph looks like
so this is what our graph looks like
now we already know that none of the
various different
probability distribution functions fit
these graphs so now we are going to
perform
non-parametric estimations
to perform non-parametric estimations
we're gonna use the scikit-learn machine
learning library
which provides the kernel density class
that implements kernel disk density
sorry
that implements kernel density
estimation
first the class is constructed with the
desired bandwidth or window size of
two
and your basis function which
in this case is a gaussian function
it's a good idea to at least test
different configurations to your data
and in this case we're only gonna try a
bandwidth of two and a gaussian kernel
uh but usually there are multiple
different kernels that you can
uh you know like that you can play
around with and you can also tweak your
bandwidth to exactly fit
the distribution that you have
now let's run this
so now we've gotten our kernel density
estimation
or now we can evaluate how well the
density estimates
matches our data by calculating
probabilities
for a range of observations and
comparing shapes to the histogram
just like we did for the parametric case
before
so again we're gonna just calculate
different probabilities
using the kernel density function and
we're just gonna plot it on top of our
histogram to see how well this
the kernel density function is
estimating
for our data so these are the
probabilities that we've got
in finally with the con with the kernel
density
estimation and now we're going to plot
it on top of our histogram
so as you can see it's almost a complete
fit
it's just left out some of these outlier
values which again are
ranging very high but overall we have a
pretty good fit
the only problem is it's not very smooth
and you can
again try tweaking the bandwidth to
different values
uh so let's just in this case try
tweaking it to
three and see how well it runs
okay so now we've got a new
probabilities and let's run it on top of
our bandwidth
uh so again we using a bandwidth of
three you can see that we're fitting
our data even better and we're again
ignoring a lot of the outliers which are
out there
so this is going to give us a better
estimation and with that we come to the
end of this video on probability
distribution function
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
also here's your reminder to subscribe
to our channel and click on the bell
icon for more on the latest technologies
and trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here